is the Fed winning no the FED is not
winning but everybody else is losing I
think it'll be a bigger recession a
deeper recession than anything we've
experienced in our lifetimes even if you
don't lose your job it's going to hurt
so Bitcoin is up about 40 to start 2023.
what do you think is driving that demand
you know the ride to zero is not going
to be in a straight line I mean there's
going to be plenty of bear Market
rallies when you look at the assets that
will do best what are the assets that
you're most excited about I think the
assets that are ultimately going to do
well are all right guys bang bang I've
got Peter Schiff here Peter I thought a
great place to start is the Federal
Reserve for over a year now it's been
talking about destroying demand and they
have done a fantastic job of destroying
investor demand but now we are seeing
the inflation numbers start to come down
we are at maximum employment uh at a 50
plus year low in that unemployment
number what is going on and is the Fed
winning or are there actually problems
on underneath all of these seemingly
positive numbers
no the FED is not winning but everybody
else is losing that's for sure
um you know they haven't really
destroyed demand
they've changed it a little bit
but if you look at what's happening
people who have jobs are spending
everything they earn and then sub
uh the savings rate is near record low
credit card debt is record high so
people keep on spending nobody is
cutting back on their consumption maybe
they're spending more money on food and
insurance and rent and less money on
other items but in aggregate we haven't
seen a reduction in spending or an
increase in savings the government
continues to spend like crazy they just
passed that reconciliation bill but the
government deficits despite what Biden
said in his uh non-state of the Union
Address the other night the deficits are
skyrocketing and so that's all
additional spending demand in the
economy
the fed the FED hasn't done anything to
to bend that curve and so I think we
have seen this transitory Improvement in
the numbers because they were really bad
and now they're not as bad
but I think that as the year progresses
we're going to see that change and we're
going to start to see a worsening of the
inflation data again something that the
markets are really not prepared for
neither is the Fed how does that work
explain so right now uh we peaked you
know just under 10 or so uh in terms of
the official inflation rate in America
it's now come down uh below seven
percent why do you think it is going to
get worse and this would contradict
there's many investors like Barry Stone
like and others who think that we're
actually going to see negative inflation
come the summer what what is your logic
in terms of why you think the inflation
data will worsen over the coming months
yeah well first of all it's only seven
percent if you look back for an entire
year A lot of people are saying hey if
you look back six months it's around
three or something like that which which
may be true but of course again the way
the government measures prices and what
actually happens to prices are two
different things so the real increase in
prices is much greater than what is
being officially reported by the
government but I think think that you
know you had this initial spike in a lot
of prices and then the feds started
hiking rates and that had an impact on
the dollar it had an impact on
Commodities you saw commodity prices
come down particularly oil prices and
higher interest rates had an impact in
housing in other areas of the economy
and so you've got some temporary uh
easing of the inflationary pressures
also U.S GDP got a boost from the
strength of the dollar because the
initial uh result of higher rates was a
stronger dollar that brought down the
cost of our Imports that helped keep
commodity prices down that also helped
boost the GDP numbers but I think all
that is going to reverse we saw a big
drop in the dollar in the fourth quarter
dollar weakness is continuing uh so far
in 2023 I expect it to accelerate and
that's going to worsen the trade
deficits and that's going to help push
commodity prices to new highs and all
that's going to put renewed upward
pressure
on the inflation numbers
when that happens what is the fed's
response so they are getting close to a
pivot I think in most people's minds but
if all of a sudden we see a real
re-acceleration of inflation data along
with uh historically low unemployment
does that give them kind of free license
to just ratchet up the interest rates
and try to destroy as much of uh kind of
this consumer and investor demand that
still exists
well you know the the real problem for
the FED might be that not only do we get
a surprise uptick in inflation but we
get a downtick in the economy you know
it's only a matter of time before we
start laying people off I mean we're
already laying people off but eventually
it's going to be impacted more
in the official numbers because right
now what's creating all this noise in
the jobs numbers are all the part-time
jobs that people are being forced to
take on because they can't get by on the
income from their full-time job or some
people may have had a couple of
part-time jobs and they needed to take a
third part-time job so that's going on
right now because if you look at the
data over the last 10 months we've
actually lost full-time jobs there are
fewer people that have full-time jobs
now than had them 10 months ago but you
have over a million and a half more
people that now have part-time jobs now
some of those people
have still have their full-time job
they're just working another job now why
would somebody who has a full-time job
go out and get a second job well it's
because they can't afford to pay the
bills with the salary from their
full-time job so they need to Moonlight
and so that's what's going on and that's
really what is impacting these numbers
as far as why the unemployment number is
so low I know a lot of people aren't
being counted as as unemployed and I
know a lot of people a couple years ago
made the decision to be self-employed
they got into the gig economy whether
they're driving Ubers or doordash or
something like that and and so they can
never be fired you know once you decide
that you're just going to work for
yourself you can't fire yourself so you
can never really be unemployed so I
think there's a lot of noise in these
numbers I think the labor market is
considerably weaker than the FED
believes or the market believes but at
some point all these layoffs that we're
getting and look more layoffs were
announced today look at a firm that by
now pay later companies stock down 20
today uh laying off I forget a quarter
of their Workforce I mean who didn't see
that one coming and I talked about the
nonsense of these buy now pay later
companies uh when they were you know all
the rage but one of the reasons that
consumers were able to spend money is
because they didn't have to pay they
just got stuff for free and they thought
they'd pay later but of course they're
going to pay never and that's going to
be the problem for a lot of these
companies because you you know they
fronted the money and now they're not
going to get it from their their
customers but you're getting more and
more layoffs you know from tech
companies you're going to see a lot more
layoffs in uh you know crypto and
blockchain all these companies you know
hired people I mean all these guys are
going to lose their jobs
um but
with I think that what's going to
surprise the FED is going to be that not
only is inflation going to turn higher
but the economy is going to turn down
and so will uh job creation and
unemployment will go up so inflation
will be stronger than the FedEx backs
the economy will be weaker now what does
it do that's the 64 trillion dollar
question is the Fed in a weakening
economy and maybe even a financial
crisis who knows what might blow up
because interest rates you know they're
almost five percent now and they're
going to be five percent pretty soon you
know we were at zero uh so that's a huge
change you know you you built an economy
around zero percent rates it can't
function at five percent the whole thing
has to implode which is a good thing
because we had a phony economy and that
needs to implode but when it does it
obviously creates a lot of problems a
lot of people are going to lose a lot of
money and that's go not you know that's
not going to be something that the
government is going to want to sit by
and just you know watch it play out they
never do they always feel compelled to
intervene and do something even if what
they do makes everything worse but will
the feds back or will the FED rather
fight inflation and say you know to hell
with the economy or the the labor market
or the financial system or the stock
market we don't care we're going to
fight inflation we don't care what's
happening in the economy or are they
going to say we we don't care about
inflation we got to go help the economy
we got to do something about uh what's
happening the economy and of course the
only thing the FED can do is create
inflation that's the only thing it's
ever done that's its only tool is
inflation so if the FED is going to have
to say yes we have high inflation but
we're going to make it even higher
because we feel that we need to do that
to help the economy or the labor market
so we're looking right now and talking
about the Federal Reserve in the United
States what's been surprising I think to
many over the last 60 to 75 days is that
the Federal Reserve has been draining
liquidity from the market they've been
creating these tighter Financial
conditions also the ECB has been doing
the same exact thing but we've seen
numerous central banks in Asia actually
pumping liquidity into the market and so
when you take the top 10 central bank
balance sheets on a net basis you find
that over the last 60 to 75 days there's
been about 500 billion dollar increase
to those top 10 central bank balance
sheets and so when you see what the FED
is doing is there some weird world where
like all of the effort and all of the
time and energy that they're putting
into joining liquidity is just being
washed away by these Asian central banks
that are actually pumping liquidity in
at a much faster rate than it can be
drained on the western world
well first of all I don't know that the
FED is actually draining it fast enough
I mean the balance Sheet's still around
four and a half trillion I mean nine and
eight and a half trillion excuse me so
it's an enormous balance sheet I mean
you know it's only come down maybe half
a trillion from from its peak but of
course the balance sheet blew up a lot
faster than it's shrinking remember how
quickly uh we we inflated that that
balance sheet the deflation is taking a
lot longer and I I don't I think it's
going to be aborted I don't think the
FED is going to continue on this path
because the the rate hikes that we've
already had are taking a toll on the
economy right now and we're just
beginning to see the effects and it's
going to get a lot worse remember it's
only been a year not even since the FED
raised rates for the first time right so
you know there is a lag between the
increase of raids and the effect on the
economy and and so we're just kind of
catching up to those effects but they're
going to be enormous in all segments of
the economy I mean not just the stock
market and the real estate market but
you haven't you know American economy
that's based on cheap money I mean
that's what it was running on for more
than a decade uh well now it's time to
pay the piper and everybody's broke you
can't pay the piper so that's bad news
for the piper who thought he was going
to get paid but it's everybody else too
because now they can't get any more uh
free music or entertainment so this is a
huge Day of Reckoning here that we're
just on the cuspuff let's take kind of
each segment of the market or each
market participant independently what
does this mean for small business owners
or individual uh investors or consumers
is there kind of a full-on recession how
bad is it when does it happen how are
you thinking about what the impact of
the situation will be on the average
American or those small business owners
well yeah it's going to be a huge
recession I think it'll be a bigger
recession a deeper recession than
anything we've experienced uh in our
lifetimes
and um you know because a bust is
proportionate to the boom and and this
has really been an unprecedented uh boom
um created by by the FED created by
artificially low interest rates and and
quantitative easing
and so this could be one hell of a
hangover that's what's going to happen
and uh you know so but different people
are going to be affected differently you
know the definition of a recession is
when your neighbor is out of work and
it's a depression when you're out of
work right so you know not everybody's
going to lose their job
um but I think everybody's wages are
going to be reduced in real terms so
even if you don't lose your job I think
that the money that you earn is not
going to go as far when you when you go
to buy stuff because I think unlike
previous recessions this one is going to
be inflationary you're going to have
recession and inflation happening at the
same time and that's what's going to
make this recession so much more painful
because even if you don't lose your job
it's going to hurt
um and I think most investors are going
to lose money I think most investors
over the last decade or two have been
channeled into the wrong assets by the
artificial low interest rates so a lot
of people own very high multiple
companies growth companies
uh and in fact companies in many cases
don't even have any earnings at all
right there was they were just
speculating on earnings in the future
but people were willing to do that when
the cost of money was basically zero but
I think as the Dynamics change a lot of
people are going to realize that they're
holding the wrong assets
and they're going to get repriced and
marked down so you know there's going to
be big losses for most investors that
you know have the Fang stocks or a lot
of these stocks that did really well you
know when the Fed was blowing up the
bubble but they're going to do horribly
when it bursts uh and you know the same
thing for you know your favorite yeah
cryptocurrencies I mean cryptocurrencies
also got caught up into the speculative
Mania and um you know the air is going
to come out of that bubble too so a lot
of people that had a lot of money or at
least they thought they had a lot of
money in their in their in their digital
wallet so they're going to find out that
there's really not much there I mean
they'll still have the crypto they just
won't have much real money if they if
they try to sell it
when you look at the assets that will do
best so you talked about Fang stocks
crypto a couple of other assets that uh
you anticipate will do poorly in this
environment what are the assets that
you're most excited about or that you
think the average individual uh likely
will end up benefiting if they are
positioned correctly well I mean these
and these are the assets that I've been
buying for a long time anticipating this
it's not like I just woke up and decided
you know I've been I've been planning
for this for a long long time in fact a
lot of people would say well you know
see I'm wrong because I've been saying
this for so long I wasn't wrong I just
knew what was going to happen a long
time before it did but I think the
assets that are ultimately going to do
well are one Commodities I think
Commodities are going to do extremely
well uh in an inflationary cycle and
that's you know all sorts of Commodities
Industrial Metals agricultural
Commodities oil and gas
so I have Investments there and of
course precious metals you know they're
you know going to do very well Gold's
the king of all Commodities and I think
it's going to do very well in a
commodity Bill Market especially if we
have ultimately end up having a dollar
crisis currency crisis and gold is you
know remodetized in some shape or form
either by the private sector or by
various governments and so there could
be a huge increase in in the price of
gold in this type of environment
but I think that there'll be a lot of
money lost in bonds paper assets I think
that people that own quality real assets
will do better and so that's the value
stocks I mean companies that actually
have big earnings right now not
companies that might earn money in the
future uh but that earn a lot of money
right now and have been earning a lot of
money in the past so that the income is
reliable and dependable and the
companies are selling goods and services
that people really need to buy and
they'll buy them I mean maybe they'll
buy a little bit less but they'll keep
buying and they'll cut back or give up
something else in order to buy these
things and so you want to own those
businesses I think the businesses
that cater to Consumers that don't have
a lot of debt and that have more
productive jobs are going to be better
because their customers are going to be
in a better position to pay and uh you
know so that would exclude you know the
US I mean some Americans will be able to
pay but a lot of Americans will be too
broke to buy buy products I think the
Emerging Markets are going to be
um you know much a more fertile ground I
think the uh you know the consumers
there are going to be in better shape
they don't have the kind of debt that
you have let's say in the United States
or some of the uh you know more
developed Western economies you have
younger populations they're still
working educated uh skilled uh making
stuff and it so they can you know
generate real demand because they could
also generate Supply uh to create that
demand and so you know I also want to
invest in in those economies I think
emerging market stocks uh will be
winners you know in uh in you know this
environment I think they'll do better on
balance than the developed markets
um and I think you know overseas markets
will do better than than domestic
markets here in the United States I
think equities will do better than bonds
but it depends on the equity I mean
because your stocks that are going to go
bankrupt and that's you know you lose
100 if your company goes bankrupt but a
lot of stocks that won't go bankrupt
investors will decide that maybe they're
worth 10 cents on the dollar or five
cents on the dollar relative what they
thought in a very different
uh investing environment
when you mentioned gold uh one of the
things that I've had previous guests
come on and talk about is the idea of
sanctioned Hedges and so obviously we
saw Russia invade Ukraine we saw the
United States and many other countries
around the world kind of coordinate and
issue uh immense historic sanctions
against that country and what it led I
think a lot of people in the gold
Community to start talking about is well
hold on a second there's a lot of
central banks who see that happening
they want to lessen their dependence on
treasuries or US Dollars and therefore
it will lead to more increased purchases
of gold in those Central Bank Reserves
one have we seen that happen in the year
or so since Russia invaded Ukraine and
the U.S and NATO levied those sanctions
into how do you think gold as a
sanctions hedge uh potentially uh plays
into any future price movements in the
asset
yeah I think absolutely that is
happening right now I think
you know central banks around the world
are concerned about the weaponization of
the US dollar and the Swiss system they
saw what happened to Russia and what is
happening to Russia now
and they don't want that to happen to
them
and and so we have created another
reason for the world to de-dollarize I
mean they had plenty of reasons to do it
anyway but we were foolish enough to
give them even more because America
benefits dramatically from the Dollar's
Reserve status and when we lose that
status and we will it's a matter of time
it's going to be a huge a wake-up call
because it's going to mean a dramatic
decline in the standard of living of
just about every American and and so you
know it's a mistake to accelerate that
process I mean if you're a politician if
you really understood it but that that's
what we've done
and so yeah I'm sure that these foreign
central banks are buying more gold for
that reason and also you know they think
the dollar is going to lose value and
they want to have a more stable store of
value as a reserve asset for their own
currencies
and so I think that's going to continue
especially when the world kind of wakes
up to the reality that two percent
inflation is a thing of the past
and that in the inflation rate is going
to be much higher than that at least you
know the way even the way the government
measures it
and that's going to result in a
re-evaluation or repricing of the dollar
and a repricing of gold I mean the
dollar is worth a lot less in a higher
inflation environment especially if if
interest rates will be perpetually
negative and and gold is worth a lot
more and you know when the markets come
to terms with that you're going to see
The Adjustment the federal reserve's uh
inflation Target is two percent you're
talking about a persistently higher
percentage uh in that inflation
measurement what do you think that
percentage would be and would that cause
the Federal Reserve to actually increase
their target uh rate from two percent to
something else in order to uh have a
higher likelihood of claiming victory in
obtaining the target
well I don't know if they're going to
officially increase the target I mean
unofficially they may have concede that
but they may be afraid of the effects of
of uh of making that announcement but of
course they never should have had a two
percent Target there's no reason
for inflation to be two percent it's not
like if it's one percent that that's a
problem and it needs to be higher the
only problem with one percent is that
it's not zero zero inflation is better
than one percent so if inflation is one
percent it's not that it needs to be two
percent and in fact if you have falling
prices if prices are going down by a
percent there's no need to force them
higher I mean we all benefit from
falling prices I mean everybody wants to
buy stuff for less money there's nothing
wrong with prices going down that's how
standards of living go up right the
things that you want to buy are less
expensive I mean everybody wants to buy
stuff for less money sometimes if you
can't afford something you have to wait
until the price comes down and then you
can afford to buy it I mean so following
prices creates demand that it it lifts
living standards and it's what we need
but you know the FED concocted is BS
that we needed two percent inflation we
didn't we needed it like a hole in the
head but the problem is now they've
created so much inflation under the
guise of targeting two percent that they
have no way of even bringing it back
down to two percent but I have no idea
what the annual rate is going to be
um but whatever it is it will not be
reported accurately because they're
going to continuously monkey around with
the CPI and and so it's never going to
honestly reflect how much prices are
going up in fact all the years that the
FED claimed we had less than two percent
inflation my guess it was at least
double if not triple two percent
when you think about other factors in
the economy that could affect the
monetary fiscal policy or how different
Market participants Act
the debt limit is a area of concern and
an area of conversation right now we
obviously hit the 31 Point whatever
trillion dollar debt limit uh there is
this period between now and June uh
where the treasury has stepped in with
emergency measures and they're
essentially playing around with some of
the different expenses that they are
responsible for kind of fact do you
think the United States debt limit gets
increased could the U.S default and how
does the debt limit play into monetary
policy in the FED decision making
well it will be increased unfortunately
because it's always increased
but every time we get close to having to
increase it the Republicans make a big
deal about it so long as there's a
Democrat president because when when
Trump was president or when Bush was
president they they didn't care they
raised the debt ceiling
but once you have a democrat in the
white house then all of a sudden you get
a few Republicans who say oh wait we
don't want to raise the debt ceiling
well we want to cut spending well why
don't you cut spending when you got the
White House you know because they don't
actually want to cut spending they just
want to talk about it
um and and so you're going to get some
Republicans talking about how we have to
get a handle on the debt but at the end
of the day we never get a handle out of
debt and we're going to increase the
debt ceiling now you know we would all
be better off if we never increased the
debt ceiling had they never raised it
the very first time and we've had it for
like 100 years but we'd be better off if
the initial debt ceiling was still in
place so we didn't have all this debt
the reason we have so much debt is
because they keep raising the ceiling
and it's nonsense to say we have to
raise the ceiling to pay our bills
if we wanted to pay our bills we
wouldn't have to raise the ceiling we
would just pay our bills the reason we
want to raise the debt ceiling is so we
can continue to not pay our bills so we
can go into debt instead of paying our
bills but the problem is paying the
bills actually costs money nobody wants
to pay the bills the politicians want to
keep on kicking the can down the road so
they want to raise the debt ceiling
again so that we can continue to not pay
our bills and have the debt national
debt go up to 35 trillion 40 trillion 50
trillion you know infinity and beyond
but the problem is going to come when we
reach a ceiling that we can't raise and
that is the lending ceiling that is the
willingness of the rest of the world to
loan US money you know because when that
when we hit that ceiling then we're done
but he the crazy part about it is
we tell our creditors
if we can't borrow more money we will
default
well we're basically telling the
creditors that this is a Ponzi scheme
because we're only going to pay back our
current bondholders if we find somebody
dumb enough to buy new bonds and then we
can take that money and use it to pay
off the guys who own our bonds now I
mean but why would you deliberately loan
money to a government if they're telling
you right off the bat if we can't borrow
more money we're just going to default
and you're never going to get your money
back you know the the politicians should
be saying if we don't raise a debt
ceiling we are going to cut Social
Security we're going to cut Medicare and
we're going to prioritize interest on
the national debt or we're going to have
an emergency tax hike we're going to
raise everybody's taxes so we can pay
the debt no they don't say that they say
if we can't borrow more money we're
defaulting so I mean so how much longer
can this go on because default is
inevitable it's only a question of when
now of course the other thing that they
can do if they're not going to default
they just print well then there's
hyperinflation and that's the same thing
it's actually worse than defaulting
when people talk about monetizing that
debt I think there's a lot of people who
are in the camp of the US is not going
to default they're going to continue to
try to monetize devalue the currency uh
we've already talked about some of the
issues in terms of the interest rate the
current state of the economy is there a
world where the FED whether officially
or unofficially just says hey we have to
return to loose monetary policy we have
to return to zero or negative uh
interest rates and therefore we are just
going to be okay and have everyone have
to become okay with living with much
higher inflation not necessarily moving
their target rate but could we see a
world over the next 10 or 20 years in
the United States where inflation is 10
or higher uh on an annual basis hey guys
what's going on I hope that you're
enjoying this conversation but I wanted
to interrupt for a quick second and tell
you about a brand new conference that
I'm hosting on March 4th at the Miami
Beach Convention Center the event is
called lyceum Miami and tickets are
completely free for anyone who wants to
come I'm bringing together many of the
most popular guests from the podcast
over the last couple of years some of
the guest speakers that we've already
announced are people like Vivek
ramashwamy from strive asset management
or Delian and Mike Solana from Founders
fund Chris Williamson from the modern
wisdom podcast Cody Sanchez from
contrarian thinking and billionaire
Christian augermeyer among many others
I've got a number of amazing surprise
guests as well some that you definitely
will not expect and others that come
from walks of life that you will be
scratching your head as to how I even
got them to show up but come check out
lyceum Miami on March 4th the lyceum was
a public gym in Athens Greece where
people used to come together talk about
ideas and debate topics that were
important to society I want to meet
people in person in real life once again
after three years of a Hiatus from real
life events and so I'm hosting the event
and as I mentioned and anyone from
anywhere can come to this event
completely for free all you need to do
is go to lyceumiami.com and you'll be
able to pick up a free general admission
ticket make sure you claim your ticket
in order to get in through the doors
lyceum Miami is going to be a great time
so come check it out come hang out with
me many of the popular guests from the
podcast and other like-minded
individuals lyceum Miami March 4th Miami
Beach Convention Center I hope to see
you there alright let's get back into
this conversation
I think so although I don't think our
creditors will put up with 10 inflation
uh that many years in a row especially
when the interest rates are well below
that and they're really getting killed
but you know inflation is a form of
default if the Central Bank prints a
bunch of money and you have 10 inflation
and we have a 30 trillion dollar
national debt we've just repudiated 3
trillion of the 30. I mean it is a slow
default that's what it is it's just a
different way of defaulting you do it
through inflation instead of just
reducing what you pay but it's the
impact is the same for the bondholders
either you get all your money back I
mean either you get all your money back
but you can't buy as much or you get
less money back but you can actually buy
the same uh as it you know let's say
there's 10 inflation if I got 90 cents
on the dollar well that's the same as
getting 100 cents on the dollar with 10
inflation or I can get 90 cents on the
dollar with no inflation
um but you know prices are going to go
up a lot more than 10 percent I mean
they can double they can triple they
could try Drupal and that is a huge
haircut you know the bondholders end up
losing 70 80 percent or more of the
value of what they loaned and you know
that's like the government paying off 10
cents on the dollar 20 cents on the
dollar what about the national debt
interest payment so between the last
three to four years I think we've paid
375 billion to 475 billion uh dollars
annually in that natural uh national
debt interest payment on top of that the
interest rate that we've paid is
anywhere between 0.1 to like 1.9 percent
uh there are a number of different uh
organizations and economists out there
saying that they believe that the US uh
will be paying more than a trillion
dollars annually in interest payments uh
for the national debt by 2030 2033
whatever not by 2030. maybe even by the
end of this year but certainly by next
year the the interest tab you know
assuming just a Fed five percent rate
right fed funds rate which we're going
to be at you know in March or you know
the you know the FED is going to hike
rates another couple you know 50 base
points or so that's what it says
um we should be at a trillion in
interest by the end of the year if not
next year but we're not going to stop
there I mean then we'll be 2 trillion
you know and what happens when the
national debt is 50 trillion and
interest rates uh are 10 well that's
that's 5 trillion a year in interest on
the national debt I mean so I mean it's
it the numbers are enormous because the
debt is going to keep going up and
interest rates are going to have to keep
going up because the more debt we have
the more inflation we're going to create
and the more inflation we create the
higher interest rates have to be so this
is an unsustainable even uh pal admitted
that what we're doing is unsustainable
it is unsustainable and when is it going
to end only when there's a crisis and a
crisis is coming because the politicians
will not act in advance of a crisis to
avert one they will wait until there is
a crisis and then they will try to react
to the crisis after it happens and so
there will be a debt crisis the only
question is when and I I think it will
be a currency crisis as well as a debt
crisis because the response to a debt
crisis is to print more money and that
creates the currency crisis describe a
little bit more in detail how you expect
that crisis to play out both the debt
and the currency crisis like what would
your expectation be with either the
sequence of events or the things people
should pay attention to
well when you know
as buyers for U.S treasuries or dollar
that I'm in debt in general disappear
nobody wants to loan money anymore
because the interest rate is not even
close to compensating you for what
you're losing especially when the dollar
really starts to fall you know then you
know your foreigners are not going to
want to loan US money uh if the dollar
is going down against their you know
their base currency yeah so you're going
to start to see a loss of of buyers and
then the FED is going to step in with an
even bigger quantitative easing program
to to pick up the slack to buy the bonds
that nobody else wants well where does
the FED get the money to buy those bonds
it has to create it and that means it
expands the money supply so it creates
even more inflation which will push the
dollar even lower and that will force
you know even more people to want to get
rid of U.S bonds assuming there's still
some private buyers around you know now
you're going to chase them out and now
the FED is going to have to expand its
QE program even more because if the FED
doesn't step into the market interest
rates really go up you know look what
happened in 1980 with volcker they went
up to 20 percent they could go higher
than that now I mean we have a lot more
debt now than we had back then uh so in
theory we you know race should go higher
now than they were back in 1980 but of
course since we have so much more debt
than we had back then the economy would
completely implode it would be just a
meltdown
so they're not going to let that happen
but the only way they can prevent that
from happening is by creating more
inflation and that's really what leads
to the currency crisis because the
markets figure this out finally
and nobody wants our dollars you know I
think it'll start abroad where
foreigners don't want our dollars but
then Americans won't want the dollars
either because they won't be able to buy
very much with them so I mean the whole
world will be trying to get rid of them
in that situation what will they want
well I mean obviously they can want real
money so they can want gold or silver uh
to the extent that there are other
currencies that are holding up better I
mean you know you know I don't know if
it's the Euro or the Yen or it's going
to be a smaller currency you know they
can look at the Swiss franc or the
Norwegian kroner there could be other
currencies although maybe some of these
other central banks will get you know
their acts together uh and back their
currency by gold I mean I don't know if
it'll be a major Central Bank uh like uh
Europe or maybe it'll be like China or
Saudi Arabia or somebody will come up
with a viable alternative that that
people will have confidence in but you
know it's easy to have confidence in in
gold and silver you don't have to accept
a government
and um you know you can't inflate the
the supply there's there's a certain
amount in existence and the supply uh
grows very slowly so you know there are
hard money Alternatives I know you know
your audience thinks oh they're going to
go to bitcoin I don't think so I mean I
I just don't see that as a hard money
alternative to anything and I just you
know there there was just some
speculative demand uh for Bitcoin
um
but um in a safe haven risk-off
environment I I just don't see that
demand there and it's certainly for you
know larger players you know you can't
put a significant amount of money into
Bitcoin because you take a huge risk
that after you buy it the price crashes
so Bitcoin is up about 40 to start 2023
it's the fastest starts since 2013 about
a decade ago
um what do you think is driving that
demand is it a risk on risk off
environment is the central bank balance
sheets just getting an injection of
liquidity is it people who are worried
about a potential USD fault trying to
get out of the system and try to find
other assets like what's driving such a
big you know kind of movement in the
price of something like Bitcoin to start
the year yeah well keep it in
perspective I mean the price is around
22 000 you know whereas last year it
almost hit 70 000. so the reason it's
had a big balance in January is because
it got destroyed in 2022 it's one of the
worst years it's ever had certainly in
terms of market cap it has to be the
worst year it's ever had as far as how
much market cap was lost during a
calendar year
um so we had a big drop you know the
ride to zero is not going to be in a
straight line I mean there's going to be
plenty of bear Market valleys and we've
seen a bear Market rally in Bitcoin
we've seen a big bear Market rally in
all of the crypto related stocks that
were down 80 90 percent last year they
rallied too really big look at the Kathy
Wood Arc Innovation
ETF which was a disaster or fund was a
disaster in a 2022 and it had a big
bounce uh so all the stuff that really
went way down went up now the question
is why well maybe there were some shorts
that covered all at once you had a lot
of shorts that covered and so that
created some some buying also I think
there is some speculation people see
these stocks that are way down and
they're like hey let me let me play a
bounce maybe you know hey Bitcoin was 70
000 and it went to uh sixteen thousand
maybe it'll go to 25 30 000. that's a
pretty good return let me get in there
and you know so I think you got some
speculative money that came in there but
I think everybody that bought the losers
from 2022 you they're going to lose
again in 2023
um you know today was a pretty bad day I
mean look at some of these stocks you
know got really beat up pretty badly it
was a technically a very bad day the way
the market reversed but particularly in
the crypto sphere a lot of these stocks
you know got shellac today uh coinbase
microstrategy you know some of these
stocks
but I think that they're all going to
make new lows you know the Fang stocks
as well I mean it's not all these high
beta risk assets
uh that bounced off the lows are going
to make new lows in my opinion early in
2023 not late in 23 I think early in
2023 they're going to make new lows and
I think what you saw last year
was a movement out of momentum into
value that's why that's why we did so
well last year I mean like if you look
at the money that I manage right at your
Pacific Asset Management my two key
strategies were you know most of our
money are we have a dividend-payer
strategy and a value strategy and for
the smaller investors we created mutual
funds that mimic those same strategies
in our separately managed accounts and
you can buy those funds through my
awesome asthma company a broker dealer
uh you could buy them at any of the
discount brokers and if you look at what
happened with uh uh um U.S news and
World Report they just came out a couple
of weeks ago and they looked at
large cap value funds and these two
funds fall into that category there are
two of the 350 funds and U.S news award
report ranked These funds not just last
year but just over three years five
years and they said okay what's the top
fund you know and they rank the top 60
out of the 350 and my two funds were
number one and number three now somehow
Goldman Stacks got to number two
hopefully I edged them out next year and
I'm one and two uh and Goldman Sachs is
you know somewhere lower but the reason
that I did so well on a relative basis
on an absolute basis we didn't make much
money last year we were positive in
those funds uh which was good in in a
market that got killed and you know and
the reason we weren't up more is because
the dollar was up ten percent and these
are all foreign funds so we had to be up
ten percent just to break even and we we
more than broke even but I think the
reason I did it really well and the
reason we were able to make up for years
of underperformance to get so highly
ranked was because of the types of
stocks that we own and the sectors that
we overweight and its value it's
dividend paying stocks it's you know we
avoided a lot of the tech stocks and the
financials that really blew up in 2022
and I I had avoided them for years
because I knew they would eventually
blow up and I don't think they're
finished blowing up and so I think that
those trends that were in place last
year are going to accelerate they've had
a reversal in January those two funds
are lagging they're up you know they're
up so far this year they're but they're
not up as much as the benchmarks because
the benchmarks still have all these
overpriced crap stocks that bounced but
as this reverses I think these
strategies are going to thrive once
again and I think that they'll do even
better this year because I believe
instead of going up 10 the dollar is
going to get killed in 2023. I think
this could be one of the worst years of
dollars ever had of course 2024 can be
even worse but I think we're going to
start to see the dog going down down and
that's going to be a big headwind for
any of the non-dollar uh you know
International strategies
when you see the dollar going down does
that mean that an asset like Bitcoin
will benefit from a weakening dollar
you know it could I mean you know I mean
Bitcoin can go up or down for any reason
right I I just don't see the correlation
that gold has for the dollar in Bitcoin
I mean if you look at the trading
most days if you see the dollar is up
gold will be down and vice versa
that's not necessarily the case with
Bitcoin Bitcoin to me is more correlated
with you know Kathy Wood Arc Innovation
with those type of stocks that's that's
where I see a strong correlation not to
a currency Market or the precious metals
Market but to other high-risk assets now
you know can some people like like you
for example you may react to a weak
Dollar by buying Bitcoin because you
think Bitcoin is some kind of digital
gold and an alternative to gold and so
you want to buy it as an inflation hedge
and and you're probably not alone there
are some other people that might do the
same thing I just don't think there's
enough of you out there and I think most
of you who think that way already have
like most of their money in Bitcoin you
know I don't think they've got a lot of
dry powder uh right now to buy buy more
Bitcoin but I also think there's a lot
of money still in Bitcoin that wants out
you know you got to for you know you got
to remember that there's a lot of people
that got into it uh because they thought
they were going to make a quick buck and
now they're kind of stuck and they're
looking for any kind of strength to get
out you always have the Wild Card of the
grayscale Bitcoin trust I mean what's
going to happen to that uh what if they
end up having to liquidate all their
Bitcoin what if all that Bitcoin that's
locked up in that trust ends up having
to go out of the market I mean who's
going to buy that
um so there's a lot of wild cards out
there
uh and then you have all these companies
that are bankrupt and you know may have
to be selling their crypto assets how
much Leverage is still in the system
um you know there's so many potential
you know bombs that could that could
explode in the crypto space so I I would
look at it as like a safe haven or store
value I mean it's just so much risk
compared to just buying gold which
doesn't have any of those risks so when
you look at uh let's say a store value
right I think that um you correctly
called out that yes Bitcoin is up 40 or
so to start 2023 but it's down I think
about 65 probably not anymore you know
check the price yes so it's down about
65 from the all-time high in Q4 of 2021
it's down about 50-ish percent or so
over the last 12 months and so depending
on your time frame ends up having a
different analysis but if you go back
kind of pre-pandemic era Bitcoin uh was
sitting somewhere in the eight thousand
dollar range is now over 20. 22 23
whatever it is gold obviously has also
gone up during that pandemic era but not
nearly as much as Bitcoin has uh and
most other assets haven't kept up with
Bitcoin either how do you think about
time Horizons when measuring a store of
value is it something that you look at
over a year or five years a thousand
years like what is your kind of
framework for evaluating these you don't
measure a store of value based on price
because you can't store a price and that
that's a an important distinction that
everybody misses Bitcoin has a price
uh and that price is determined every
day by the supply and demand I mean you
can see the price it's trading it
doesn't have any value you don't need to
have value to have a price because
people could value anything right value
is is totally different and so what is
the value of gold apart from its price
you know what is the value of that metal
right well it's all of the things that
gold can be used for for which you know
there really are no substitutes if you
really want the the the quality or the
effect whether it's making jewelry or
conducting electricity or wherever the
applications are
there is a value
for gold now there's going to end up
being a price you know assigned to that
that's going to change but there's value
there and when you're storing gold
you're storing that value the metal
itself and all the things that you could
do with the metal
Bitcoin doesn't have any use other than
the fact that I can buy and sell it but
apart from that in and of itself there's
absolutely nothing you can do with it
you can't make anything out of it it
doesn't matter how many you have if I
have a hundred ounces of gold I can make
a hundred times the amount of jewelry as
if I had one ounce of gold if I have a
hundred Bitcoins I can't do anything
more than if I only had one or if I just
had one Satoshi which is why I don't
even think the 21 million Bitcoin is
relevant it's the 2.1 quadrillion
satoshi's that you need to look at
because there's no difference I mean so
you're really buying a bunch of
satoshi's and there's you know there's a
whole bunch of them out there uh you
know because all Bitcoin is is an
arbitrary bundle of satoshi's that you
know doesn't again it doesn't matter how
many you have you still can't do
anything with it so Bitcoin doesn't have
value and so you can't store what you
don't have you can't store a price
because price is purely dependent on on
supply and demand and and so will there
be demand for Bitcoin in the future I
don't know I mean I know there's going
to be Supply right we know that the
supply is there we don't know if there's
going to be demand and I think that most
of the demand for Bitcoin has come from
people who thought they would get rich
buying it you know and the institutional
demand that came in late to the party
like you know Anthony scaramucci with
the sky Bridge funds you know why did
all that money get go in because they
thought they could get rich you know and
then there was also a degree of fomo
that oh you better buy this you're going
to miss out on this huge move you know
and so you had some people coming in
but I don't think those buyers are there
anymore I think the big drop in Bitcoin
has scared off all that money and now
all the fraud you know some of the
biggest players I mean look at bankman
freed he was like the poster boy of
crypto and he was a complete fraud you
know and if scaramucci couldn't see that
this kid was a fraud then how are you
going to trust his judgment right I mean
he's telling you Bitcoin is great but he
also told you that Sam bankman freed was
great I mean what kind of judgment is
that you know and so a lot of people it
wasn't just FTX you had a lot of other
you Celsius or Tara loon all these
various companies and now what's up
gemini or I can't even keep them
straight they're all blowing up but
people start to think wait a minute you
have all these frauds all these scams
maybe everything is a scam right maybe
you know people are just getting away
and then there's gonna be more
regulation coming Congress is coming in
you know trying to you know with more
heavy regulation in the industry so
these are huge problems so I don't see
where the demand man is going to come
from
uh for this for for Bitcoin and Bitcoin
competes now with over 20 000 other
cryptos that are also vying for part of
that you know crypto pie you've also got
all kinds of equities that are now
linked to crypto whether it's the
grayscale trust or microstrategy or
coinbase or you could buy those things
right as a bet on crypto you don't have
to actually buy Bitcoin so you got all
sorts of things that compete for what I
believe is going to be a shrinking pool
of potential buyers and remember you
like to look at time frames Bitcoin was
000 in December of 2017.
so you know we're five years past that
and Bitcoin is about the same price
right you know and and and if I'm right
I think Bitcoin is going to crack 10 000
this year how low it goes we'll see
maybe it gets to 5 000 I mean it'll
balance my guess it won't you know again
it's not going to be a straight line a
zero but so at some point this year I
think you get ten thousand dollar
Bitcoin and then you're gonna compare it
to twenty thousand dollar Bitcoin in
2017 and now you're like you know six
years later you know it's down 50
percent I mean
that that's significant you know nobody
expected that you know back then
everybody was so excited it was supposed
to be hundreds of thousands by now you
forget how bullish everybody was uh a
few years ago you know everybody now
wants to go back to the beginning you
know when Bitcoin was under a thousand
or under a hundred yes sure of course if
you bought it way back then you did
great the problem is not that many
people bought it way back then and the
people who bought it back then didn't
buy that much money worth most of them I
mean some people did and now they're you
know billionaires or they were
um but most of the people who own
Bitcoin are losing money they didn't buy
it until 2021 or 2022 and they're down
50 or more and you know they're not
happy about that they don't like the
fact that they bought Bitcoin they
didn't expect it to go down this much
and of course a lot of people that own
Bitcoin are gonna need money soon they
could be unemployed soon you know how
are they gonna get money to pay the rent
you know the landlord doesn't want their
Bitcoin they're gonna have to sell it
you know they want to buy groceries the
you know the supermarket take Bitcoin uh
so there's a lot of hodlers I think that
are going to have to sell some of them
are going to be forced to sell because
they took out loans imagine when Bitcoin
goes below 10 000 I think there's gonna
be a lot of people that are gonna be
forced to sell their Bitcoin even if
they don't want to they'll have no
choice uh because they they have to
repay their debts you made an argument
about Bitcoin not having value outside
of price if we look at gold and use the
same argument I believe that the number
is somewhere between seven to ten
percent of gold is used for jewelry uh
Metals Etc and the rest is really used
as store of value maybe that number is
wrong you'll correct me if I if I have
yeah yeah I'd say 50 percent of the gold
production annually goes towards jewelry
the new gold is produced so that's the
number one use is Gold is used for
jewelry why do they say that the only
seven percent or so of the market cap is
uh is for jewelry like I said fit you're
saying 50 of the new production why is
it the new production right that's
that's taken out of the mines is is
consumed in the jewelry industry why is
so much of the new production going to
jewelry versus other YouTubers because
that's because there's a jewelry
industry that needs it right they need
they need to make jewelry they need gold
right
um but yeah I mean I think about 20
percent
maybe at the numbers of the gold is held
by individuals for you know store value
I mean central banks have a big chunk of
it too so let's just let's just use for
the purposes of this conversation let's
say 50 of gold is used for jewelry uh
you know conduction all the use cases
outside of store value and 50 whether
it's individuals companies uh central
banks whatever is used for store value
in that argument would you say that if
all of a sudden people decided oh I
don't want gold for the price right kind
of for that quote-unquote store value
that there'd be a 50 reduction in the
market cap no it it doesn't work that
way okay and you know the reason that
gold
is you know
a store of value is because if I have an
ounce of gold
that ounce of gold is not going to Decay
it's not going to rot you know it
doesn't have Half-Life you know it's
it's it's it doesn't change and in fact
even if I have gold in jewelry
that piece of jewelry could be melted
down and and the gold is exactly the way
it was before it was made into jewelry
it has all the same properties so the
properties you know don't don't diminish
over time so no matter how long you hold
on to it so
people are going to need gold in the
future I mean and in fact there's
probably going to be more uses for gold
in the future I mean there's a lot of
use for gold and medicine and Aerospace
and as we have advancement advancements
and that you know area I mean there's
probably going to be demand for gold and
uses for gold that we don't even
you know know about yet you know based
on how unique gold is and the things
that gold can do you know there'll be
you know more things that it's used for
just like there's more uses for gold
today than there were two three hundred
years ago look at all the gold issues in
the chip industry you know they didn't
have that before they didn't they didn't
use gold for that
um so you know gold is a very valuable
rare metal it is the most useful metal
of all the metals on the periodic table
now sometimes they use other metals
because gold is too expensive and that's
one of the things that would happen if
the price of gold really started to fall
people would start using gold instead of
copper or instead of you know because
now all of a sudden it would make make
sense if at a certain price point you're
going to use gold but the reason that
you might use copper is because the gold
is too expensive so you can't use gold
you got to use something that will still
work but there are some areas where you
can't use copper you have to use gold
and then whatever the price is you just
have to pay it
um but you could you know you could
historically look at the price of gold
and you can compare it to the price of
all these other Commodities I mean it
you know you could look at wheat you
could look at soybeans look at Copper
you can look at oil and you can look at
gold and you can say what are these
historic relationships I mean they're
you know they're they're those
relationships should should hold and
they and they and they do hold over time
you know you can't do that with Bitcoin
you don't you know there's no historic
relationship between the price of
Bitcoin the price of anything else you
know there's no way to know you know uh
how much you know Bitcoin be worth
versus a bushel of wheat there's just
absolutely no way I mean you can't do
anything with it but the market can uh
make a judgment about how much an ounce
of gold is worth we're all to do Bush
low wheat you can you can make that
relative price
you mentioned fraud earlier uh in number
of crypto companies whether they
committed it they're victims to it uh
there's a daisy chain of Leverage
there's a bunch of these kind of issues
across various companies hedge funds uh
products but we've also seen a number of
allegations over the last two or three
years uh some further back things like
Nicola where there was a uh allegations
and eventually courts found individuals
made uh you know kind of misleading
statements to investors and things like
that all the way up to most recently
Hindenburg research has levied you know
100 page report against adani
um in kind of the entire group in India
and many of the things happening there
how much of uh the nefarious action or
maybe even just ignorance that ends up
hurting investors is a sign of the times
and bull markets versus you think it's
industry specific you've long talked
about kind of crypto but is it a crypto
thing in your mind or is it more so just
good times and now all the tide goes out
you see who's naked if you will well
look when when you have easy money and
you have a kind of Casino like
environment in Risk assets
you're going to have a lot more of that
obviously you're going to have you're
going to have more more fraud more get
rich quick schemes
and you know people will have that
appetite and they'll have the money in
order to to gamble and of course you
know it feeds on itself I mean your
neighbor starts making a bunch of money
in crypto and he starts telling you how
rich he is and maybe you start to see it
because he bought a brand new car or
something and so uh you you get into it
you know it kind of feeds on itself it
becomes contagious
and you know crypto I think was almost
like a perfect asset for that you know
this it had a real sexy story
um you know when I first heard the story
you know I I just was you know I
understood money too much to to get
taken in on it
um and so I just kind of like dismissed
it and and didn't realize that so many
people would get sucked into it but I
think the people who took large
positions
in Bitcoin
and then did a great job of promoting it
I mean it's a you know a huge success
story for the people who got in early
and pumped this thing up and cashed out
right so a lot of people made a bunch of
money off the marketing of this you know
pyramid Ponzi Chain Letter however you
want to describe it I mean it has
characteristics of all these things but
with zero percent interest rates and the
FED printing all this money you know
that helped create the story like yeah
we need an alternative to the dollar you
know and and oh golden Gold's no good
Gold's uh old school Gold's analog this
is digital it's like the internet you
know it was all this sexy BS you know
um you know it's you know there's an
expression in in my industry you know
you sell the sizzle you know not the
steak the problem is you know with
Bitcoin there is no stake you're it's
all Sizzle but they you know they were
able to sell it and so a lot of people
got into it and then part of the prop
thing was
a lot of celebrities you know
entertainers uh sports stars you know
influencers got into it because it's the
perfect platform for them in in the
internet age where you can have millions
of followers on Instagram or Tick Tock
and some company could say hey here's
some of this coin you know go out
and talk about how it's going to the
moon and we'll give you a bunch and then
you know you could tell all your fans
about it they're gonna buy it and it's
going to go up and you're going to make
a bunch of money I mean that's what
Kevin O'Leary did too when he got into
um
um I uh FTX you know I remember I you
know I I I was doing an interview this
is what I did the interview with Celsius
when I I debated mishinsky and I said
hey you're running a Ponzi scheme I
figured that out right away from the
stuff he was saying
um but the the lady who was moderating
it asked me you know well when are you
going to change your mind like like
Kevin O'Leary and I said at the time and
this is you know a year and a half ago I
said well Karen O'Leary only changed his
mind because he was paid to change his
mind he became a show for a crypto
company he was negative on bitcoin until
somebody paid him to be positive on it
right and and so he sold out
you know and and that's the same thing
that his buddy uh you know
um Mark Cuban did from Shark Tank he was
very negative on bitcoin until all of a
sudden he got into you know nfts or
whatever how he did and all of a sudden
you know he you know I'd laser eyes or
whatever all these guys got sucked into
it because there was so much money
everybody was making so much money at
the height of this bubble
um but
the bubbles popped now a lot of people
don't recognize that yet I get it you
know because hey bitcoin's still at 22
000. so yeah it's still a big number
there's still a big market cap
um one of my last question what happens
in a couple years let's see where it is
one of my last questions for you is do
you think that celebrities
promoted Bitcoin or gold more you got to
remember that celebrities rappers
athletes all the people you're talking
about influencers kind of this whole
cohort of people with audience they have
gold chains gold teeth they're talking
about uh various things
former president Donald Trump's got a
gold toilet Gold Room the whole thing
which asset do you think has been
promoted more globally Bitcoin or gold
well when rappers you know have their
bling you know and they're wearing gold
they're not promoting it as an
investment as a way to get rich it's a
fashion statement it's a way to display
your wealth I'm so wealthy that I can
afford this gold toilet bowl or whatever
for Donald Trump but so they they
weren't promoting it as a way to get
rich Bitcoin was sold
to buy not to wear it around your neck
but to get rich so you can afford to buy
gold and and put it around your neck it
was it was a way to get rich so
absolutely Bitcoin was was promoted far
more heavily than gold the only
celebrities that have ever really
endorsed gold
and they're not those type of
celebrities you know you'll see gold
copies like I I I'm associated with
shift gold I started it but I don't own
it anymore but I I help uh you know deal
with their their marketing and I make
sure I I have input into their products
and what they're selling because they're
still using my name and I'm I'm still
promoting the company and I'm associated
with these guys and so you know they've
got to do the right thing or I I will
end my Association so uh customers are
are getting served as well now is when I
own the whole business
um but there are gold companies that
hire celebrities
to recommend them usually they're talk
show hosts because a lot of the ads are
on you know conservative talk show you
know guys that you know are talking
about inflation and the big deficits and
you have to buy gold so their
celebrities do get paid
to recommend not necessarily goal but
recommend that you buy gold through
whatever product whatever company rather
has paid them to go out and promote the
gold but then what ends up happening is
those companies end up ripping off their
customers because instead of selling
them you know a low markup product like
the type of products that shift gold
cells they end up selling these faux
numismatic coins where they're marking
up the coins 20 30 40 50 or more above
the value of the gold and that's how
they can afford to pay these celebrities
to to recommend them is because any
customers who come to these firms as a
result of those endorsements get ripped
off
but that is much smaller scale compared
to you know what we saw you know I mean
no gold company had a Super Bowl ad I
mean you had four different crypto
companies I've never seen a gold company
I can afford to advertise on the Super
Bowl
um you know it's funny
I did a live interview the other day
um and the guys started talking about uh
chat GPT and I said you know I I had to
use it my son was had been using it a
lot and having a lot of fun with it but
I asked them you know we're talking
about Goldmine so why don't you ask the
chat chat the chat GPT who's the who's
the world's most well-known gold bug
and we came up with me right that's
that's what that's that and then it got
like Mark Faber like after me and and
then that was it I mean it shows you
like there's nobody out there like that
that's really associated with gold more
than me now I I we I also asked it to
say well who are the biggest Bitcoin
critics and my name didn't even show up
and so many people you know Warren
Buffett Charlie Munger uh
um uh
um
Dr Doom uh uh what's his name
rabini Paul Krugman
um uh Jamie Diamond I think there's a
whole long I didn't even show up were
you jealous were you jealous significant
when it comes to criticizing Bitcoin but
when it comes to Gold the only one they
could find really was me so it's like
gold is not anywhere near the Hypes like
that Bitcoin is not even close
when you talk to your son and he says
Hey I want to make a decision I have a
hundred dollars uh and I want to make
sure that I hold as much of this value
over the next 50 years
you tell them to buy Bitcoin of course
not why would I tell them that now he
might he might think that that because
again he's 20 years old doesn't know any
better
um you know I'm trying to teach him but
you know there's always a you know
rebellious side to kids right you always
want to rebel against your father uh you
know make your own Mark Do Your Own
Thing
and the younger generation always thinks
they know something that their father or
their grandfather didn't know I mean
that's that's not new I mean that's how
history uh repeats itself uh maybe when
my son eventually has a son of his own
uh and he learned his lesson the hard
way about Bitcoin maybe his son will be
you know you know taken in by some type
of similar uh Ponzi and he'll be able to
say listen son let me tell you when I
was your age I I got all you know
suckered into this thing called Bitcoin
I don't know if you've ever heard of it
or you remember let me tell you a little
bit about this thing Bitcoin and uh you
know maybe maybe he'll have more success
than I did or maybe it would be the same
brah dad you know what you're talking
about this isn't some Bitcoin it's
Bitcoin whatever that is you know this
is this is different
but um you know that you you can't
repeal human nature unfortunately but
you know the central banks pay play a
big part in in in storing this stuff up
and they certainly did with the the
Bitcoin Mania and all the other cryptos
I mean not just Bitcoin obviously uh you
know because you have 20 000 plus coins
out there
and I use the word coin lightly because
they're not actually coins and in fact
you know most people don't even call
them cryptocurrencies anymore they
dropped currency it's just called crypto
right because they realize that it's no
people aren't really using it as a
currency so it's just crypto yeah that's
what it is it's you know but what the
hell's crypto it's it's nothing do you
know how many Tran how much annual
transaction volume of gold there is
is that number uh no but transactions
what type of transaction you talk about
and are you talking about like on the
Futures Market people trading gold
Futures no no the volume there are you
talking about physical gold like actual
gold like Bitcoin on chain right so not
uh futures or anything derivatives or
anything but actually on chain uh in
2021 had 13 trillion dollars of volume
during that year yeah I mean that's
trading volume right it's not it's not
much buying a cup of coffee not on the
exchanges not on the exchanges on the
actual blockchain in terms of
transaction now what they're transacting
for we don't know right so could it be
someone transferring a certain amount
from one wallet to another wallet uh for
trading purposes maybe but we're taking
out exchange traded volume and we're
talking just about transaction volume so
there's that much about this so that's
the volume that's happening on no
exchanges just if I were to give if I
was going to send you some of my Bitcoin
you're talking about that money going
from my money moving moving one wallet
directly to another Bitcoin moving from
one wallet to another wallet well you
you called Bitcoin money it's okay we
got you yeah it was that was a mistake I
meant Bitcoin
um and so when that uh uh those
transactions 13 trillion now again
there's a bunch of caveats what is it
for no no when you say 13 trillion you
mean 13 trillion times Bitcoin moves no
13 to another 13 trillion dollars worth
no oh 13 trillion volume worth worth of
it so you're not talking about 13
trillion transactions no you're talking
about 13 trillion of market cap moving
correct and so when you think again I
don't know what that is I don't know
like you have some whale that moves uh
I'm saying a million the reason why I
went to another wallet the reason why
it's interesting to me is because
um it's more than master card in a given
year right and so again is it a direct
comparison there's debate but I would
wonder if gold is more than the 13
trillion of Bitcoin in 2021 wow I would
think it'd be less I don't think gold is
moving around like that yeah
um so but so technically but that's the
difference
or American Express these are these are
payment mechanisms
where money is being paid you know used
as a method of payment so Bitcoin may
have been used more than MasterCard for
media there's no there's not even it's
not even close uh how do you know I mean
I look I I don't go into stores and see
you know signs you know for Bitcoin I
mean I I I I would guess because why
would people be using a digital currency
it's native to the internet wouldn't
they be using it on the internet more
where you're not going to see why why I
mean they could use it in the real world
too but I don't go to websites where you
know I mean shift gold takes you know we
have a thing with with Bitcoin where we
work with bit pay but I I I would say
that the interest in accepting Bitcoin
was greater
among merchants
in 2017 than it is now I think they've
lost it that's not true I don't know
that there's no interest but I just
think that you know there they've lost
it because they realize it didn't work
look remember
um Tesla initially said we're gonna
we're gonna sell uh our cars for Bitcoin
and and Elon Musk tried it for I don't
know a month or so how long and then
just said you know it doesn't work and
he stopped it didn't want to do it
anymore
um and so you know I just don't see it
working as a payment in fact most people
in the industry will concede that
Bitcoin is not a good
medium exchange uh for payments that
it's just digital gold it's just a store
of value which of course it's not you
know they're trying to reinvent it as
something it's not
uh it had there's no real use case for
for Bitcoin none
no not even for speculation you can you
know I mean do you do right now do
people uh use it for uh ransomware you
know may yeah but maybe there's better
cryptos that are more secure and more
private that you could use you know to
to commit a crime than Bitcoin so I I
like I like talking to you because you
make absolute statements like there's no
use case but I think if I pushed you a
little bit you would say that actually a
use case of Bitcoin is speculation right
but that yeah but that's not an actual
use case that's what yeah I mean it's
like a fake you have to be apart from
speculation yeah I can speculate on
something that's useless but yeah I mean
I will concede you that there are a lot
of ways to gamble today you know you can
buy lottery tickets you can go to a
casino you can bet on the Super Bowl
Sunday or you can buy Bitcoin right yes
so you know Bitcoin competes with all
those forms of gambling I'll give you
that
Peter I always like giving you a hard
time I appreciate you sharing so much
information especially about the economy
uh you you have a a very great grasp I
think of uh the economic machine also uh
how much the Federal Reserve seems to be
struggling with controlling what's going
on
um if people want to find you on the
internet uh where should they go and and
if they want to find out more about Euro
Pacific where can they go there
well they could find me on the internet
uh you can look above my shoulder your
Pacific Asset Management if you have a
portfolio and you're interested in
having my team manage it for you you
should give us a call we have all sorts
of strategies even if you've got some
money in Bitcoin you can't have all your
money in Bitcoin I think I remember you
told me you had half your money in
Bitcoin so at least at least you won't
lose the other half and maybe you know
that's that's the way that I can I can
manage
um you know in strategies that will will
do well I think in a inflationary
environment in a week dollar environment
so uh happy to take on new clients we
work with investors all around the world
not just in the United States and again
people can buy my mutual funds through
their existing brokerage account pretty
much all the major discount brokers have
my funds on their platform so you can go
in and buy them there uh I'm all over
social media you know I don't have as
many uh Twitter followers as you I mean
at one point I had more but you just
blew by me in the Bitcoin bubble but I'm
closing in on a million I've got like
you know 920 some odd thousand so you
know I'm I'm gaining on you a little bit
maybe I don't know maybe I'm falling
further behind I'll tell you that's fine
I'll throw you a party when you get to a
million
but
um you know I but I'm on you know
Twitter that's where I I am most often
and if you read the tweets they're
almost all mine I mean some of them come
from shift gold and uh but most of the
tweets are I write myself in this way
I'm communicating with people through
Twitter kind of almost the way Donald
Trump did so I've been using that
platform
um in fact I even pay Elon Musk now uh
the eight bucks a month just to do my
part I had a check anyway after many
many years but now now everybody's got
to check if you if you'll pay the eight
bucks
um but I wanna I wanna contribute to the
cause somewhat but I'm on you know
Facebook not as much anymore I'm on
Instagram I'm even on Tick Tock you know
we're putting out a lot of tick tock
content trying to reach the the younger
people with with my messes so yeah try
to follow me on all these social media
platforms spread the word get your
friends to follow me and listen to my
podcast you know there's a brand new
episode that just came out today uh the
Peter Schiff Show I commented on Biden's
State of the Union Address
yesterday so to get my take on that just
go and listen to the Peter Schiff Show
you can listen at shiftradio.com you can
go to my YouTube channel listen to it
there or if you're you know a podcast
you know on iTunes or Stitcher or these
various other platforms just search for
the Peter Schiff Show uh I know you've
got that that was a great picture that
was a great pitch
yours is like the world's greatest
podcast or something like that just the
best well the world's best the second
best
ride all right Peter I appreciate it
very much I always enjoy talking to you
yeah I mean so I'm out there I'm all
over the internet all right we're ending
it though we're ending we got to end we
gotta I got things to go do I can't talk
to you forever all right I love you I
will see you later thank you so much
talk soon bye all right so long